you
when I start run with the following
Asgar said you've invested in over 500
companies now if you take the 15 year
span that you've been investing that's
about one company every six days so the
question is how do you I've heard it's
stated that way how do you organize
yourself to be able to invest in so many
companies and in general what's your
stretch so like the like the
introduction said the the the best
decision I ever made from a macro point
of view was back in 1994 when I teamed
up with Ben Rosen and we had this crazy
thought we were both as gray-haired as I
am today
in 1994 and we said let's only invest in
this thing we call the Internet so one
of the reasons that that I attribute my
success to is that I have stayed only
focused on the Internet I haven't gotten
distracted with healthcare or Green Tech
or anything else
now since 1994 the Internet has
completely exploded and we could almost
be criticized for not focusing on some
sector of the Internet which in fact we
do have a sector focus but we take a
portfolio approach where we try and
invest in the top 10 companies in each
of these sectors and hope that one of
those ten you know becomes the company
that blossoms because you don't know
that the day you invest the venture
capital community tends to invest in one
company per sector and hope that that
company's going to win and that's a more
rifle focused approach where my approach
is more portfolio I am now concerned I
haven't been answering your questions
can you can you restate it though
process that many deals right yeah and I
wanted to make that point so now that's
out of the way
well actually it's it's it's been a lot
more than that but if you go back to
1994 it was me and Ben Rosen for a
couple of years and when we got to
investing in one company a month I said
oh you know we can't process the deal
flow and especially we don't have the
time to do the due diligence on the deal
flow so that's when we formed angel
investors LP in 98 which was a twenty
five million dollar fund and then
remember this is the height of the
internet so you know people were
investing very rapidly in internet-only
funds so we did a fund the very next
year which is kind of unusual 1999 we
raised a hundred and seventy five
million dollar fund now in that fund
from 98 to let's say 2003 we had a staff
at our peak of 13 people in other words
we charged a 3% management fee we capped
the GP salary at 300k each but a 3%
management fee gave us enough money to
hire a lot of people to manage that huge
portfolio of the 500 companies I've
invested in 225 of them were at this
peak of the internet 9899 so at that
time we had a huge staff when the bubble
burst
we actually very quickly reacted when
the stock market crashed and
May of 90 May of 2000 and I told all of
our staff hey we're not investing
anymore this is gonna be awful everyone
go find another job
and we basically triage that 225 company
portfolio waited for Google to go public
Ask Jeeves had already gone public in
that portfolio which gave it some return
but Google was the monster return and
the venture investing in angel investing
is a hits business in my opinion but I
have lots of facts to prove it
because in the 98 99 funds and I'm back
to not answering your question I'm sorry
but I'm thinking of interesting stuff
78% 78% of those 225 companies went out
of business that is how traumatic the
the bust the you know the the bubble
bursting in 98 9 1999 how traumatic that
was because most of the persons the
people in this room don't remember that
but if you were me I never believed the
market would come back the way it has
and Google really helped bring it back
we were fortunate enough to be investors
in Google and that basically paid for
those funds so and we ultimately sold
those funds the balance of that
portfolio after Google went public so
now we're in 2003-2004 start I started
angel investing on my own again one now
at that time period I was all alone and
then I couldn't keep up with the due
diligence because startups started to
percolate you know from 2000 to 2003 for
there wasn't a lot of startup activity
there was no money for it there was no
appetite for it I mean this valley was
very dry at that point but I started
investing again in 2003 and when the
deal flow got active and
I teamed up with a fund called baseline
which helped me process the deal flow up
till two years ago when we got really
excited about real-time data and we got
so excited about that we spun off a
baseline and we started SV angel SV
angel today so baseline at about four
people SV angel has five people so my
whole theory about investing is if you
have great deal flow then you get great
deal flow by helping entrepreneurs
getting a good reputation and then they
come back and then they recommend you
that's how you get good deal flow but
that's easier said than done but once
you get the great deal flow you have to
process it and do due diligence on it
and that's what you need four or five
people for we see five new deals a day
all from people and email addresses that
we know and we turned down one out of 30
I'm sorry we only invest in one out of
30 that we see so that's that's 29
turndowns for every one that we invest
in and these are all people that we know
so that's the hard part of the business
but that's a lot of work you know doing
the due diligence because you want to
invest in the winners so let's go back
to to Google example and can you tell us
a little bit about a when when you got
involved with them and more generally
what stage do you like to to become
involved in companies and then sort of
how did that work with Google so we like
to invest at the very seed stage one two
or three co-founders usually at that
point the three people are all
cofounders of the company
and that's when we like to invest that's
the vast majority of our investments
Google definitely was in that bucket
Google started in 1997 no probably 98
now that I think about it I found out
about the company at Vivek Ranadive
holiday party in December of 98 and I
ran into David Cheriton who's a
professor at Stanford and David was an
investor in the angel funds and the
angel funds had all investors in them
who were unique to the internet it was
inherited entrepreneurs or Stanford
professors and at that party and it was
funny it was a black-tie party and I had
never seen David Cheriton at a black-tie
I don't think I've seen him in one sense
if you know David Cheriton he's not
prone to black-tie and I I said hey
there's got to be something going on at
Stanford I want to know what it is and
you know give me the name of a company
that I can go home with and he said oh
there's a really interesting one called
backrub and that was the name of Google
in the very very beginning was back rub
and I said well what does it do and he
said well it's search quality search
based on PageRank
and relevance and PageRank as determined
by popularity by users and that summer
before we had just taken a Steve's
public so even though I'm not an
engineer I knew that I knew the search
space pretty well and I said my god I
want to meet that company tomorrow and
he said oh no no they're not ready to
see any funders yet because they had
already gotten the money from Andy
bechtolsheim Rahm Shriram Jeff Bezos
and David Cheriton there were four
people that did that original angel
round so they had enough money but he
IBAD him and three three months later he
said okay they're ready to meet you
so we went in and met Google on
University Avenue and it was probably no
more than six people and I brought one
of my partners who was technical I
always hook up with somebody who's
really technical and we decided ahead of
time because of our knowledge of Ask
Jeeves and because of what we heard
about this search engine we we felt like
this was something big so I said I'll
keep them busy talking and after the
demo we'll ask him you know can you just
keep playing with it so I talked to
Larry and Sergey Bob Bozeman you know
kept playing with the search and halfway
through the interview he just nodded to
me like you know go for it
this thing is awesome and so I said to
Larry and Sergey we want to invest like
right now and they said well we're gonna
get the the big V C's first but maybe
you can help us close the VCS and
Sequoia was one of the VCS they wanted
to invest because of sequoias
partnership with Yahoo and Larry and
Sergey were smart enough to say we're
gonna need distribution for this search
engine we're gonna want to deal with
Yahoo let's go get the VC you invested
in Yahoo to invest in Google and so they
basically said you helped us close
Sequoia and you'll get an allocation and
so that's how we got an allocation in in
in Google so you use the term badger II
but here's here's a cute story no no so
this getting the VC round done was not
easy because it was KP for AOL and
Sequoia they wanted to VCS VCS don't
like doing deals together especially at
the height of the internet and so
Sequoia and KP didn't want to work
together and we kept saying hey if you
don't work together maybe we'll just do
an angel round and Larry and Sergey I
could tell we're getting really serious
about this so we called KP in Sequoia
one day and we said guys neither one of
you are gonna get this because Larry and
Sergey are saying hey if these guys
don't hurry up and walk
work together we'll just do a big angel
round and they asked me can you raise 10
million and an angel round and I said
for this you bet I can
and Sequoia and KP called me in a
Starbucks coffee shop in Foster City in
1999 I said great and they agreed to
work together which meant I was gonna
get a lower allocation but better for
the company because getting Google and
Sequoia behind you early is the best
thing you could do so we were super
happy for Larry and Sergey but I hung up
the phone and I said to my wife this was
a historic phone call and she laughed
and she goes oh all your calls are
historic and I said no no no I want you
to really remember this one because this
is gonna be a huge company and she she
does remember to this day that I I said
this one is going to be huge and we kept
telling our LPS for years you know we
talked about Google all day we should
probably stop but but what a hot
technology Google had and in the early
days of Google investors didn't get it
they said isn't it just like the rest of
them and we'd say no go use it it's
actually relevant it delivers relevant
answers and therefore it's going to be a
huge company and we don't know how but
it will be and sure enough many of our
students here so if I'm not an engineer
or a scientist can I be involved in
technical company you are a political
science major correct and so you said
you always get somebody to help you but
take it back one step how do you even
know who to get and and have you ever
felt disadvantaged because of a lack of
a technical background well I haven't
felt disadvantaged because of not being
technical myself because every step of
the way because I know I'm not an
engineer
and I'm not a PhD I've always made sure
for every fund that we had a very
technical person that we can turn to who
can actually do a code review if they
have to usually they can get what they
need just by talking to the entrepreneur
but so a non-technical person can
definitely succeed most of our founder
teams if they have four people the
fourth person is usually the business
person bizdev marketing person and so if
you're not technical in a founding team
you can be that person one of the things
you do is you get involved with the
teams above and beyond just investing so
so when you do that you're helping the
you're helping to organize a technical
company do you ever run into problems
there well no because we've done our due
diligence through our technology person
that we have at the time so oh well in
terms of our advice to them our MO is we
get involved at inflection points during
the company's history by inflection
points I mean we help them get a great
angel syndicate once we decide to invest
we lead them completely through the VC
round helping them pick the VC's
back-channeling to the VCS getting the
valuation right getting the VC round
done and then when traction happens then
companies need lots of distribution we
help companies get their distributions
so if you need to deal with Google Yahoo
IAC AOL will go get that to happen with
the management of those companies we
will also help on recruiting will help
with management turmoil every company
has management turmoil at some point in
their history but when those inflection
point events aren't happening we are not
there
so we're like the doctor on call we
don't take board seats we only get
involved when the entrepreneur needs our
help
so what I mean the the long-winded
answer is we don't get involved in
product strategy we don't get involved
in engineering decisions when we invest
in the entrepreneur we assume he or she
knows the product in the engineering and
in the codebase because we don't get
involved in that we don't want to be
involved in that because some a lot of
our companies end up morphing into each
other spaces today we're in gowalla and
Foursquare for example we're in blippi
and swipe ly so we don't get into
product strategy we don't want to so you
know we we just want to help you know
with those rifle-shot company defining
events and it's funny when our companies
get to liquidity and and they call up
and you know we're congratulating each
other so many of them lately say it's so
weird you were only involved in our
company four times for like a week each
but now when I look back at what we did
those are the four things that got us
that made us big you just swooped in
helped us and got out because we've got
to go help the other company well one
thing that I think that turning this
subject matters for the angel community
that might be useful for the group to
hear is it's pretty clear that the angel
community has a variety of different
ways in which they interact with
companies both in terms of funding and
also in terms of helping out so how do
you so if you just think about the agent
community are you at one end of the
spectrum and what's the other end of the
spectrum in terms of the way in which
you interact with companies well there's
you know if you take the angel investing
category because it is becoming a
category there there are people who
invest just as an individual angel
themselves and they usually do you know
1 to 5 investments a year I personally
think that's a hard way to do it I think
you need to build a portfolio of
companies so somewhere in that portfolio
is the winner and then there's there's
angel groups like ours SV angel is a 20
million dollar fund the managing general
partner is David Lee I don't want to be
a fiduciary so David Lee an ex-googler
lawyer and engineer is the managing
partner of SV angel and our investor
base is all Internet entrepreneurs
themselves just like the angel funds
were so it's the founders of many of the
great companies in Silicon Valley and
they contribute to a lot of the deal
flow so that's you know SV angels kind
of a friends-and-family fund and then
you have this new group called super
angels or micro VCS and these are people
who have institutional money behind them
and they act much more like a fiduciary
and I I don't like the term super angel
super angel because they go and raise
this money from the same people that
Sequoia and KP and everyone else raised
their money from
I think super angels are just small VC's
the bucket of money they have is smaller
but they're actually competing with Sand
Hill Road as far as I'm concerned and
it's just how big the bucket of money is
that that you have what I think you need
to look at is which one of the partners
in these firms is going to add value to
your company because raising money today
is a nothing's easy you know starting a
company is not easy that's why I've been
quoted and it's true that I think anyone
who has the guts to start a company
should get funded because it it is not
easy it's a toner
work but but getting funded hopefully if
you've got a great idea you'll get
multiple people wanting to invest and
then it's about picking the partner in
the fund that you're getting money from
who you think is going to add value who
has the biggest rolodex who has the best
business sense you know who's going to
help you when there's management turmoil
with great advice that's what you need
to look for it's the individual not the
funder who invested in that fund so if
you have a twenty million dollar fund
and you are call yourself an angel how
do you differ from a small VC well we
don't have we don't take any money from
institutional investors who then have
other investors that they answer to so
super angels are also what I would call
super fiduciaries you know they they
have institutional money that also has
investors watching them there's three
pairs of eyes watching your money and I
personally think that takes your eye off
the ball all I want to do is help
entrepreneurs I don't want to be a
fiduciary
so with SV angel it's a very unique
relationship but I have the best of both
worlds but that's that doesn't occur
very often you said something that I
think is worth noting about the way you
describe your fund sort of friends and
family as opposed to institutional
investors and there turns out they're
people in the world they don't have
friends and family who can support them
and one of the things that I think is a
hallmark of Ron Conway is that you treat
your your entrepreneurs as if they're
our friends and family I know about
something they appreciate so let's just
spend one more minute on the angel
community because it's changed a lot in
the last 15 years you describe sort of
what it is now how do you see this this
moving on and one of the things that
seems to have happened is that some of
the VCS have pulled out of the
early-stage funding which is
where you are and you see this
continuing like this or do you expect
that to change over the next 5-10 years
well I I think it's ever-evolving
what I like about it is there's more
people investing which says more
companies get started which means
there's more innovation in Silicon
Valley or elsewhere in the United States
and you know I really do believe that
Silicon Valley must live up to its
legacy and be the most innovative place
on earth and that's part of the reason I
do this the fact that there's there's
more funding sources say there's going
to be more great companies and more
great ideas funded which says we will
dominate in in technology a lot of the
VCS though most of the VCS that I know
on Sand Hill Road wants to invest at the
seed stage and do invest in the seat at
the seed stage and it's a misnomer that
they don't KP and Sequoia make and and
benchmark these firms when they have
conviction about an entrepreneur they
will invest 100 150 and then go go to
the next level the problem with that is
if they don't invest in the Series A or
B round there's a stigma on oh well why
didn't Sequoia invest in the next round
and it actually makes it harder for the
entrepreneur to raise money because
everyone says well why isn't Sequoia
investing and that's why you don't see a
lot of entrepreneurs doing that but as
far as the super angels I mean the
number of super angels or micro VCS out
there in in the last couple of years has
been doubling or tripling every year and
I view that as a good thing for the
ecosystem one of the things that I know
everybody in the audience wants to know
more about him so let's turn
now as advice for for aspiring
entrepreneurs and we've covered a little
bit about technology you come a little
bit about your philosophy by the way I'm
assuming from what you just said that
you don't invest in second and third
rounds is that true we typically do not
so you avoid the crowd why did you not
invest yes yeah okay yeah we avoid that
and and in our case when you're
investing as an angel you usually don't
get asked anyway but you know two
exceptions would be I invested in
follower follow-on rounds of AdMob and
Twitter I think those are be vivid
examples of companies that were far
enough along that you know a shrink
would say are you crazy you know not to
take your pro rata in those types of
companies but in general we don't
because because I'd rather spend all of
my money investing in three
entrepreneurs starting a new Co that's
what I enjoy you know just writing
another check for AdMob on Twitter yes
it puts money in the bank reason I do it
it puts money in the bank so I can go
invest in more startups but that act
itself is not as exciting as investing
in a brand new Ross startup let's turn
now to advice for aspiring entrepreneurs
who think they're at the stage where
they should be raising some money and so
let's start with when in the evolution
of an idea of an opportunity do you
think an entrepreneur ought to approach
an angel
how far along do they need to be and and
what what advice would you give them on
that well my advice is to bootstrap as
long as you possibly can and there are a
lot of companies where the entrepreneur
bootstraps and all the way to
profitability let's use Michael
Arrington as an
example TechCrunch everyone must note
Michael Arrington at TechCrunch he is a
bootstrap entrepreneur he started
TechCrunch and never ever took a nickel
and sold it to AOL a month ago for a lot
of money I mean he's a wealthy person
now that is the best scenario now how
did he do that he got quick traction and
he monetized it quickly enough and he
was able to hire enough people and
always make a profit so how does that
translate here you know trying bootstrap
as long as you possibly can and try and
get some traction that you can show
investors so that you do get multiple
investors bidding on your company and
you can get a higher valuation so you
don't get diluted as much so the best
case and Michael Arrington is the
exception not the rule
most companies do have to go out and get
funded but if you get funded where you
have written the initial program and you
can show some traction ie there's X
thousands of users that's much easier
than getting funded with you know here's
an executive summary and you need a good
executive summary regardless here's a
great executive summary but the code is
half done we're gonna go to beta in six
months but we have five people and we
can't bootstrap it anymore that company
you know is not gonna get a optimal
valuation so the longer you can
bootstrap get the program finished
release it you know don't procrastinate
Google the father of you know release
products to beta and iterate iterate
iterate I'm a huge believer in that now
we still have very prestigious companies
who don't do that they want to wait till
it's perfect and then release it and
happen to disagree with that so and
that's why you know companies are
becoming more successful is is Google's
the one who took the stigma off of
releasing beta software but get the
product out there get traction and then
raise money that's that's the optimal
crossover when you've done that gun as
far as you can then would you suggest
they try to find an angel or try to go
to the VC community well most people at
that what are the conditions under which
you would go to an angel versus the vo
VC I it's all about the amount of
traction you have so there's no doubt in
my mind that if you can get funded by KP
Sequoia Excel benchmark Greylock right
out of the gate that is a better thing
for your company but those those VCS are
going to want to see more proof points
they're gonna want to see you know a
business model of some sort although
they didn't on Google but the product
was so spectacular it it overcame that
and they're gonna want to see user
traction and huge growth so if you if if
you're if you go from your Facebook had
a tiny amount of angel financing so
maybe if you can just forget that that
happened that Peter Thiel put in a
little bit of money with a few others
Facebook Excel came in and bid against
the Washington Post six years ago and
they they had skyrocketing growth and
that allowed them to go directly to the
VC community and get an eighty million
dollar valuation it was like unheard of
but they had proof points and everyone
knew that you could advertise to that
audience
so so if you can't leapfrog to the V to
the VC for sure you should go and find
the highest quality value-added angel
who's gonna open up their rolodex to to
finish rounding out the angel syndicate
because we invest like 100 to 200 K most
companies raised a million to start or a
half a million so no matter what you
need a syndicate of angels not just one
angel and so the lead angel better go
get other great angels to invest because
that sets the pedigree for your company
from day one onward so if you can get
four high pedigree angels to invest
you're already a hot company but they're
not going to invest unless you've got
some market traction you're the products
up and running and and and you've got
some amount of growth the lifeblood of
Silicon Valley is growth you know how we
pick our market segments anything that
grows at a couple thousand percent a
year that's a market I want to be in as
long as it's in the internet there's
nothing we don't do any market research
it's all about growth we love growth
it's the lifeblood of the valley so if
you show any investor growth they're
gonna give you money I think we'll open
it up to the audience to see 30
questions out there about keeping you
from the world series so right here are
you so investing exclusively on Internet
companies are you looking at branching
out in the near future other industries
we're exclusively internet and we're
sector focused right now on on what we
call real time which is an e which is a
lot of companies believe me it's
anything where users are spontaneously
contributing content to the web so you
know any any QA sites any Content sites
the flash sales space these are all real
time companies especially Twitter you
would be the flagship company of
real-time data internet-based company
sometimes they deviate from that
particular segment so we will still look
but you know probably 75% of our
investments are a hundred percent of our
investments are in the Internet
seventy-five percent are in this
strategy around real-time data and
that's because it because of the growth
what are a couple of investments that
you overlooked and were very successful
and what could have the entrepreneur
said to convince you to invest the the
most famous is salesforce.com Marc
Benioff reminds me every time he sees me
it was it was right in 1999 when the
when we believe the market was going to
crater and it did crater and we couldn't
agree on the valuation so the only thing
he could have said was okay I'll let you
invest cheaper and at the time he had
plenty of investors and so we didn't let
us do that if we're starting from zero
and we want to be you in about 20 years
what are the kind of things that we'll
need to get right well for sure I would
go get an operating job in a company you
know I I co-founded Altos computer and
then after that that was ten year stint
then I went in and acquired a company in
the software space that was a five year
stint I did not like being an operator
but it gave me very valuable experience
I don't tell an entrepreneur anything
that I haven't done myself it was all
say you need to fire that person and
they'll say wow that's pretty harsh well
no no no I I have fired hundreds of
people in my career it's not easy but
you got a you got to be decisive
so I'd get an operating job and then
once you get a big enough bucket of
money start angel investing but angel
invest you know with a syndicate that
you enjoy working with and and I would
find you know if your technical finds
someone who's a good market ear so that
so that your little fund is well rounded
social media is a huge space today and
David Lee and I are are the the old
farts of angel investors we have three
people who are 25 or younger and we
couldn't do effective due diligence
today on most of these social media
companies without that team
so whatever segment you're going after
make sure you have you know the the
right people to help you do the due
diligence great deal flow great due
diligence equals a good portfolio and I
laugh at these 25 year olds that we have
one of whom is my son because in five
years they'll be stale we will have to
go if social media is still a very huge
high-growth sector and I think it
probably will be in five years we'll
have to go find a 20 year old and say
tell us what this is because I I mean I
everyone probably knows I don't use
these services but I understand the
dynamic of the services and it's I'm
getting all that data from 25 year olds
so let me just go back to something you
said earlier and I'm not gonna
paraphrase what you said it has to do
with the personal attributes that have
made you successful and you said
something about aggressively questioning
people being persistent so any other
personal attributes that you think the
young man out there who wants to be in
your shoes should well I you know I
would be decisive
when you are an angel investor yo trust
your gut
you know we invest in in the
entrepreneur first in the idea second
and the idea second by a longshot
it's all about the chemistry we're gonna
have with that entrepreneur because the
idea is all morph a lot so you need to
be you would need to become a good judge
of people so to speak and that's I've
been doing after investing in 500
companies and you know talking to ten
per investment that's five thousand I've
talked to weigh over five thousand
dollars with the nurse so within ten
minutes I have a real feel of I think
that's gonna be a great entrepreneur and
we're investing and I don't care I don't
care what the idea is that's the point
you if you want to be like me that's the
point you want to get to it's a lot of
its intuitive about the people just
pushing you honest one more time right
you said deal flow is the key thing to
get so take yourself back to was in 1997
or when you started your first angel
fund how did you begin to get deal flow
well from 94 to 97 98 Ben Rosen who was
then the chairman of Compaq and I had
done about 40 or 50 investments together
and Ask Jeeves was one of them and we
actually sat in the board meetings and
and turned them into business
development sessions it's the only time
we would participate because we said hey
this is a great idea but unless we go
get you know distribution deals were
these eight publishers we're not going
anywhere and we went and assign those so
we got a we got this great reputation
established where all the Ask Jeeves
team when their friends would say hey
I'm gonna start a company they would go
hey that Rosen and Conway were really
helpful you ought to go to
to them and then when we raised our
funds in 9899
we went to Marc Andreessen Jeff Skoll
Pierre Omidyar the founders of Yahoo
eBay
those were the investors in those 98 99
funds they had just become wealthy and I
said why don't you invest in the next
generation of the Internet you're busy
at your jobs but you're gonna get lots
of deal flow Marc Andreessen and you're
busy building Netscape refer to that
deal flow to us we'll make sure even if
we don't invest we'll try and get them
funded elsewhere so we we really like
helping the ecosystem when we turn
somebody down many times we'll say hey
go try that angel because we think they
will be excited about your company in
your sector how do you feel about ideas
or companies that could be easily
replicated by large companies and maybe
targeting to be bought out like when
people come to you and say well and you
say I hear a lot like whoa what's
stopping Google from doing this in a
second or something like that well so
companies in a cluttered space depends
how cluttered the space is I think
wellness today and photos there's two
spaces that when somebody says that to
me I say my god I can recite 50
companies in that space now we still
listen to it but we think those are
pretty cluttered so we'll want to hear
more about it the the but we'll probably
most likely turn them down the exam the
best so a better example would be I can
think of five companies in the space but
it's an interesting space but there is
no intellectual property barrier to
entry then I'll look to the entrepreneur
how fast can you execute how fast can
you make a decision how fast can you
hire a team and we will tell the
entrepreneur do you know you're in an
execution play
this space is cluttered there's these
five people tell us how you can out
execute those other four companies and
there always is an entrepreneur who says
here's my angle and I say wow you will
probably execute best therefore you'll
win because these are huge spaces
Facebook you had plenty of competition
but they executed so you look for the
four the one that that that will execute
the the group texting space right now
today is hot as hell there's four
companies going after it we've made a
bet and it is an execution play it so
they're very vivid examples of very
exciting spaces that fit your example
perfectly and it's all about executing
let's say Google when Google could enter
Google could enter it is almost every
company these days what kind what kinds
of questions you asked your entrepreneur
in that case it depends what segment
that they're going after I mean we would
get really deep about if they're going
after Google or Facebook I'm hoping
there is some intellectual property
advantage if it's just an execution play
going after Google or Facebook we
probably won't invest but if they have
intellectual property that's very unique
then we'll take a look and invest well
we invested several years ago when a
company that called Blekko that just got
launched today it's in every news media
outlet and it's a search company but I
think it's going after a segment of
search and it has very deep intellectual
property and that's what we think that
advantage is
what's how long do you typically advise
your companies what type of runways you
typically advise them to take before
they get to their full series a and you
see your model changing as the early
stage sort of series a adventure
industry shrinks so I'm not sure tell me
if I'm answering this because I'm not
sure even I have the question right but
we we the companies usually raise a half
a million to a million in the angel
round that should get them you there's
got to be something to show so hopefully
thousands and thousands of users and
maybe some monetization and you want to
depending on where your traction is if
you have lots of traction you can raise
money a little slower if you don't have
a lot of traction four to five months
before you're out of money you better
start raising that next round or open
the angel round at the last valuation is
that what are some of the more promising
monetization models because I'm not sure
the mic was working well here's the
space that we didn't get into we're in a
few startups that are in it now but the
flash sales / flash marketing space
these are phenomenal monetization
schemes and I mean schemes in a positive
vent Gilt Groupe and Groupon are
fascinating companies led by defining
entrepreneurs I should have answered
when I said salesforce.com I should have
said gilt groupe I was offered to invest
in gilt groupe and didn't and and that
that is a phenomenal company with a
phenomenal monetization model twitter is
going to end up with Promoted Tweets I
think that's going to be a phenomenal
monetization model Facebook with
traditional ads is a phenomenal
monetization model but if you look at
the flash sales space all kinds of
different tweaks of the monetization are
taking place in that space and it's
really early days we haven't seen half
of the creativity on how they're gonna
monetize hi work can you tell us about
what are you seeing out of hot trends at
the moment and what do you see at the
out of hot spaces we should look into
especially well I just talked about
Flash marketing mobile mobile overall is
monstrous I mean computing is moving
from the computer to the mobile device
in every way shape or form Gaming is is
massive growth anything this
location-based is massive growth and
location-based you know with commerce in
it which is where Foursquare for sure is
gonna go and then there's a brand new
space that we're looking at right now
heard first at Stanford Oh - OH online
to offline there's a company and two
examples there's a company called
shopkick which you walk into a store
that has an lbs device it knows you're
in the store and as you're walking down
the aisles it delivers information about
what's in that aisle and coupons and
specials that that allow for instant
monetization and that's a KP Greylock
backed company and and we're lucky
enough to be investors as well and then
a company called Milo which gathers
inventory of
all the local stores around here big and
small so you would you would go to Milo
because people you know once you decide
what you're gonna buy you just want to
know it's there when you go to the store
you don't want to drive there for
nothing
you you see that they have inventory you
reserve it you drive over and you pick
it up that's just two examples of what I
would call online to offline this is
gonna be another multi-billion dollar
web opportunity have business
backgrounds and we're thinking with lots
of different ideas do you think we
should be more concerned about the idea
or the team I would be much more
concerned about finding the right
co-founders and then getting the right
co-founders to agree to the company the
market the strategy it's all about the
team now that's just my bias you know
Don Valentine at Sequoia spoke here
somewhere at Stanford a month ago I'm
dying to hear it in this room in this
chair good I love that darn Don
Valentine was the VC who invested in
Altos computer the company that I
co-founded that went public in 1982
and he's a rockstar he invests and in a
panel a week ago I said yes
I disagree why Combinator startup school
I said yes I disagree with Don Valentine
Don says the size of the market
determines how excited he gets so I just
don't want to mislead anybody here this
is this is the criteria I use there are
other angels many other angels out there
where it's all about the idea and hey
the team you know let's hope we can work
with the team and then you got the Don
Valentine which is it's all about the
market size that they're going after one
last question
I was just wondering we we hear a lot
about the big successes and we know
there are a lot of companies that never
make it and I'm just wondering how many
companies end up kind of in the in your
portfolio in the middle of the road
where they may
have trouble attracting VC funds but
they have cash flows enough to sustain
themselves and if there is a critical
mass there when do you decide to engage
or disengage if you have companies your
portfolio that are humming along but
they're never gonna be the next Google
well we only have so many hours in the
day
we never disengage we become less active
because the company doesn't need our
help but 40% of the companies we invest
in today will go out of business so
that's why I'm saying anyone who has the
guts to start a company I hope they all
get funded because entrepreneurs should
know 40% of you are going to fail you
you return no money now that's a lot
better because I'm an optimist that's a
lot better than when the bubble burst in
78 percent failure rate so but but the
the companies in the middle where
they're not hits
that's what M&A is for 80% of our
liquidity events will be via M&A there
is nothing wrong with M&A ask omar homo
who sold AdMob to Google for 700 million
dollars or the Zappos founders 2 billion
to Amazon and YouTube you know 7 not 1.6
billion to to Google there's nothing
wrong with M&A so those companies should
be very proud of themselves especially
if they have positive cash flow and say
hey we're not gonna go public but let's
merge into another company let's even
merge into a private company if we have
to and reinvent ourselves but M&A is the
vast majority of liquidity events for
startups and going into it you should
absolutely realize that and not be
embarrassed about it it's awesome you
know going public is not easy I think we
have to make that the last question
thank you
very much for coming